tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo nuovi
dio sono fa vj oggi siamo su sto
regolando queste cose come se avessi
acceso la macchina fantastica mi sento
un pilota di formula 1 oggi domenica e
quindi siamo su è più vista la cosa che
non ho mai detto nella mia vita una
frase proprio nuova detto questo dire
che possiamo cominciare con la prima
stickman pogo fight sempre paura
leggeresti nomi e poi vedere che bello
infatti mi sembrava che cosa dalla stiva
scatta un attimo fa mi capire e
protestate te la cavi bene 0 non c'è
dubbio su questo che narrava ti passa
morendo da solo perfetto ok ma cosa devo
fare qua
sai a madonna non è una falce quella un
cazzo di di bazooka stato misto
inglobando una falce come se fosse una
gnocca e bellissima sa cosa bravo steam
e intanto il tizio le fa le pippe al
manico fantastico stranissima la madonna
minchia che che mai e la [ __ ] ragazzi
ha fatto è un combattimento senza
precedenti è bello in malora come
rimasto il tizio davanti bellissimi se
importo la spina dorsale zio questo ha
leggermente mancato il bersaglio ma ok
ebbene sì vecchia tecnica sui [ __ ]
forse si è fatto male ma forse è stata
una cosa è la madonna che scatenò cazzo
ma preso non sono morto però mi ha
staccato le gambe vabbè boss è la
madonna che grosso è caduto male su cade
careca decade è appreso colpe nei
ragazzi mi ha preso col pene e sono
morto mica che corsa che cosa però
schivata tutto scrive cazzo ho perso un
piede ma vabbè sono scarpe nuove questa
ragazza un passato da foot locker prima
e l'ho preso che belle scarpe ragazze
non mi servono eccolo lì vai così a
piedi nudi senza i piedi proprio che
nell adesso cade cade sulla scarpa
equity piace la scarpata regalo guarda
da regalo ma prima me ne vado a [ __ ]
ce l'ho fatta incredibile ragazzi ce
l'ho fatta senza i piedi perché in fondo
ragazzi piedi non servono un cazzo via
così finto non so come non voglio sapere
nient'altro di suo livello è stata
abbastanza strano farlo melle cipro
cos'è sta roba mio con enti snoop dogg
ma cosa
non rende tanto vero mi fa strano
ok sono stato ucciso da un pacco di
patatine rete che le foglie patatine
fanno male non era uno scherzo cioè non
era uno scherzo quando me lo dicevano
madonna quel cappellino che ho scritto
sul web tra noi e bellissimo ragazzo sei
livello più bello della storia è caduta
una playstation 4 p occhiali da mlg la
canna illuminate c'è di tutto e sto
livello bellissimo complimenti per il
livello di è più il più figo che abbia
mai visto nella mia vita è stata
un'esperienza proprio incredibile grazie
di questa perla del fan lo scazzo vuol
dire panca ora questo sfondo verde
bruttissimo mi dicono che lì è vabbè
cazzona team complimenti al livello più
tranquillo del mondo in senso mi
geographic per bello po più su ancora un
po ma niente caduto un [ __ ]
un'emozione che parte proprio da dentro
mi viene da esprimerla proprio dopo aver
giocato a questo livello
wow che bello siamo il save your song
che mi se mi piace un casino falsa roba
perché non becco mai
come cazzo fatto non lo so neanch'io
cosa fa si muove lo se sei morto zio non
vinco my ass
vabbè è successo mi me ne farò una
ragione spagnolo spyphone neanche questo
riesco mai vediamo se stavolta è la
volta buona proprio anche se ne dubito
prova infatti mi sembrava troppo bello
per essere vero iniziato a fare i
livelli a vincerli subito orca merda ma
che sfiga
oggi non so cosa mi è preso ma sono
abbastanza abbastanza stronzo lo sai è
di che dopotutto segue è l'ultimo the
che sono andato los angeles non so che
s'è incazzato ma me ne frega un cazzo
ho vinto ho vinto ho vinto voglio le
medaglie subito grazie magari anche un
po di colla non so se serve dentro una
sventola avventura nella stanza da letto
ragazzi non avevo idea black si vuole
penn in the bedroom yesterday bello
allora 10 su 10 il livello più bello
della mia vita complimenti cioè io
salvai l'amica a livello un livello che
esprime della non ho mai fatto livello
del genere la prima volta e giuro
wow è stato molto difficile ragazzi
basta co sti cazzo di addomino cose
domino posso fare ma veramente come fa
ma no ho scelto l'unico pirla col quale
non possa arrivare al bottone fantastico
dai che spinge ma come tra tutti quelli
che potevo c'è proprio nonno cia che
cazzo tie dye vice ma no suo detto
stronzo bravo no spinge nota bravo bravo
cazzo no no no no no no me la dai
e allora sei stronzo no vabbè sarà al
livello più difficile della storia ma ci
devo riuscire me ne frega niente dai
cribbio da devi andare su appendere sul
bravo bravo bravo bravo veloce no
preferivo giocare a chieti mario lega
credetemi più che una semplice dai porca
merda sì sì cazzo ce l'ho fatta ragazzi
è stato è alquanto difficile mettiamo ok
go into the room
non sono andato nella stanza ma ok va
bene così perfetto è stato difficile
dovevo premere un bottone e non ci stavo
riuscendo perfetta united freddy's world
trovo cos'è starò a noble scusate non so
neanche leggere fantastico cosa vuol
dire che se becca una roba sbagliato a
becco freddi abello passaporto africa
muoiono nel 90 per cento dei casi perché
ci sono un miliardo di rob è però vabbè
ma è impossibile vince la star o la
braga golden freddi sede o peccato alla
testa di golden frey che bella dov'è la
vittoria
dove è la vittoria sempre avanti alla
chiave jazz pronti alla chioma good and
ho vinto perfetta mi dispiace per la
testa di freddi ma oggi ho vinto così
gta san andreas pohl space to start
fatto delle cose sta rock ma se il serio
che figata è noto degli e lo triangle
formi una ragazza bellissima sta cosa
non lo so io sì j gusti
non ho fatto in tempo a leggere va beh
no chi non son ballast o mio dio è la
madonna che cazzo è un bazooka ma
veramente posto queste cose chi è che ha
fatto sta voglio le medaglie up che
piovono ma [ __ ] a crepa in realtà
ragazzi è morto solo che non vuole darlo
a vedere
e finito così ma che ora nomi che vi sto
prendendo benissimo accordo ragazzi
faccio per i miei livelli perché ancora
da un pezzo che non faccio questa roba
mi avranno mandato tante cristo nate che
la metà basta fa vj la nutella con 2t
nutella ti prego fai questo livello e ti
prego non smettere mai di collegarci a
giornata volto bellissimo su temi video
ciao bello al alla si chiama super la
cia la alla grazia e nutella si scrive
con una t però ok nutella si è corretta
ragazzi e corretta andiamo dietro che
c'è la nutella dietro dai è di casa un
po di spina dosato chiamo la nutella
qualcosa lo sta facendo la madre coi
figli cosa fa queste cose sporchi in
pubblico
babbo non ancora fini cosa vuol dire
come faccio che ho solo un baratto ma
che ora c'è la buona tale che si è
potuta la nutella bastardo è sempre un
giorno di merda quando babbo natale ti
fotte la nutella ragazzi c'è una roba
normale
e vabbè è stata l'unica a l'unico modo
unico modo per farlo era sa era questo
praticamente ok
voglio la nutella spingi qui a ciò cosa
ma non come faccia spinge non c'è niente
c'è steve che è morto e depresso proprio
la nutella sono depressi michele
guardavo come depresso che dondola pure
li mortacci sua va beh non importa basta
che spingi spingi spingi come sapeva ma
[ __ ] fa vj verso sfrutta solo tu
puoi battere la
brutta prima che sia troppo da amico mio
che problemi hai fammi capire cosa vuoi
dire puoi battere la frutta cosa tipo
fruit ninja
ok non ho mai visto della frutta
assassina cioè la frutta che vuole
uccidermi con un'ascia ragazzi buttati
che è morbida amico io ma che cazzo di
problemi famiglia i quiz fa vj mancino
destro regia il destro ma io l'ho già
visto il traguardo quindi allora
ascoltami dio prima di fare un livello
la prossima volta pensaci due o tre
volte che poi lo fai perché no proprio
no ok fa vj verso sud la nuova gara
mortale contro fa vj come il nuovo
personaggio cos'è cosa koichi eque cosa
dovrebbe mai essere quella roba ragazze
io sarei quello ragazzi cos'è non è
possibile dato mistero sono scarsissimi
mi ci voleva una merda sa bene per
pensavo di vincere almeno io non sono
morto prima ora come vada in guerra come
faccio lo sborone in impennata fanta
bravo zio bravo fai vedere chi sei fai
vedere chiedere no ma sei andarci in
bici e farvi i complimenti ragazzi
magari se mettiamo alla rotella sto
povero cristiano che non sa andare
ancora in bici tipo a vent'anni
bravissimo come è così che va in bici è
bravo porta in alto il nome di famiglia
ai complimenti e carico e che tutto lui
ma bloccati che mi ha bloccato lascia
zio complimenti sono anche un genio
ho vinto ho vinto l'importante è che io
abbia vinto non so come ho fatto a
rialzarmi da terra ma ok comunque
ragazzi conclude episodio se anche voi
credete di andare in bici meglio di come
ci vado io che non è che ci voglia molto
è però ok lasciato mi piace fatemelo
capire così dovrò tirare fuori quella
cazzo di pc prima o poi puoi vedere che
cazzo succede spero che video vi sia
piaciuto e cosa i ragazzi servito da
piaciuto lasciato momento mi piace anche
la voglia di facebook e come ogni video
trovata una descrizione se non siamo
riusciti scrittrici big bore prossimo
vinitaly stava ammazzando prova beh beh
ragazzi